this is pretty fascinating as I've said
tap taps or how everybody gets around in
Haiti these beautifully colored painted
buses in there
painted by artists with icons this is
anthony tony'
yeah and you are from Haiti yeah I'm
from Haiti are you an artist yeah my
gosh I'm a visual artist tell me what
you've done I wanna clock in the morning
mm-hmm my girlfriend just broke up with
me I was crying at night and I was like
if I die I'd go out oh I stay home to do
what I love and then I decided to make
the illustration oh my god this is
fantastic I would love to see this on a
tap tap there'll be great
that possible that would be we're gonna
make this happen oh I'll be good I have
to cuz I'm up there with you think about
it yeah there's Rihanna
there's Lionel Messi yeah Jesus Jesus
and then Conan the pool I think yeah
right yeah
so this all happened because you broke
up with your girlfriend broke up with
you
yeah once it gets out that you've done
this you're gonna have many options okay
you are my personal portrait artists
thank you in Haiti that's an official
position nice and when it comes great
power and lots of ladies
responsibilities no no no with great
power comes lots of ladies never spray
to miss wrong I hear the first Asian
superhero - oh you did yeah I'm a comic
book a Haitian superhero yeah terrific
tell me about him his name is Joe what's
his name - tau tau I love that what's
his superpower you can teleport himself
and he can also use his energy if he can
teleport himself is that because there's
so much traffic in port-au-prince that's
that's the yeah y-you came up with the
idea right can I say two towns greatest
power he can turn a breakup with a
girlfriend
Anthony before you go I want to present
you with something we are Team Coco and
I want you to have a tango this is a
shirt now there's one problem what is it
I found out that Coco has a meaning we
didn't know anything about we found out
here that Coco means and you can say it
what does it say don't be scared see
that's one of the reason you guys broke
up you were afraid I wanted to think now
- tell Forrest she's the one who brought
me here where is she
what is your name that - you are
gorgeous you're beautiful
how long have you two known each other
oh wow now he's single are you single
[Laughter]
nothing's nothing because he is now Team
Coco we looked up the word for the male
part
always a man of my word I commissioned
Anthony to execute his vision and within
24 hours I was immortalized on Haitian
public transport to check out Tony's
outlook including his Haitian superhero
go to gto calm
you